Let's go to some interesting posts I noticed
on the David Pakman show subreddit.
Of course, the David Pakman show subreddit.
Now approaching 16,000 of our viewers and
listeners who are subscribed@davidpakman.com
slash Reddit the first one from a user name
to 12 tribes called simply speak English writing.
Republicans will tell you this is America
and in America we speak English well.
It's time to, we tell Republicans to speak
English and we need to do so ourselves.
We need to speak English, not Latin in English,
we call it bribery, not a quid pro quo speak
English and some people pointing out, it may
not just be bribery what happened with Ukraine.
We could be talking about extortion.
We could be talking about witness tampering.
Increasingly as we have threats to whistle
blowers and the outing of whistleblowers or
alleged whistleblowers by Don jr, which we
will talk about later on in the program.
Uh, also by the way, when I saw this saying
we should tell Republicans to speak English,
I thought it was a reference to Donald Trump's
very poor command of the English language,
but it wasn't.
It was about something else.
Here's a funny post conservative contributions
to society.
This is so good.
I'm wondering what you all can brainstorm
as conservative, right wing or Republican
contributions to America in the last hundred
years.
I'm thinking positive contributions like the
left in America has brought us an endless
amount of from the new deal welfare state
women's rights, civil rights, workers rights,
consumer protection and environmental protection.
The one point I keep coming back to as a possible
positive contribution is that conservatives
push to expand the consumer economy as well
as the size and scope of the presence of our
military around the world.
Of course, this has brought back a world of
negative consequences on us and that same
expansive consumer economy with regulations
rolled back to achieve it has exploded inequality
and strained the fabric of our society to
a near breaking point and huge parts of the
rest of the world despise us to the point
of picking up arms against us on official
and unofficial battlefields.
Help me out here.
What have conservatives done for us?
So you're getting to something very important
here and this is what you have to understand.
To them.
Blocking anything from happening is a contribution
because conservatism by definition wants to
conserve what is already there.
Blocking the government from doing things
is considered a contribution to society for
them because they don't want government doing
things unless of course you need gay marriage
is blocked or you need rules about who's allowed
to go in bathrooms.
Then all of a sudden the government needs
to immediately act to stop immorality or whatever
it is that they say, but that's why we are
at a disadvantage.
They win merely by gumming up the process
of democracy and preventing government from
doing things, preventing the left and Democrats
or whoever from doing things.
That is their ideology.
So we are at a fundamental disadvantage and
you are correctly pointing out that when you
talk about the accomplishments, they're a
con.
What they see as an accomplishment is just
preventing anything from changing, preventing
government from doing things.
Period.
Join the discussion@davidpakman.com slash
Reddit very exciting stuff happening there
every day.